il n'y a pas que sur terre que les
éléments peuvent se déchaîner à des
centaines de kilomètres au dessus de nos
têtes le climat spécial peut également
se détraquer sous l'effet des tempêtes
solaires et des perturbations majeures
qui surviennent sur notre planète
c'est pourquoi la nasa vient de lancer
gold un tout petit satellite de 40 kg
chargé de surveiller étroitement lié en
affaires
cette couche de la haute atmosphère qui
se trouve tout juste en bordure de
l'espace et qui nous protège des rayons
ultraviolets émis par le soleil les
sites crucial parce que c'est cet
endroit où par exemple tout et
télécommunications se font les gps entre
autres et donc tout ce qui va affecter
cette couche affecte un peu une
quincaillerie électronique qu'on utilise
au sol la station spatiale
internationale et les innombrables
satellite qui orbitent la terre se
trouve également dans l'ionosphère
raison plus de déployer un outil
efficace pour suivre de près la météo
spatiale avec goal la nasa sera en
mesure de fournir un portrait complet de
l'activité dans l'ionosphère à toutes
les 30 minutes
maintenant avec ce satellite qui est
lancé on va être à grande distance on
veut être sur une orbite géostationnaire
donc à presque 40 mille kilomètres
d'altitude au dessus de la terre et donc
à cette grande altitude on a un point de
vue global sur toute la terre on va voir
un hémisphère complique gaulle fait
partie d'une nouvelle catégorie
d'instruments scientifiques plus petits
et moins coûteux que la nasa développe
de plus en plus fréquemment si jamais il
ya un pépin on en perd qu'un c'est
malheureux mais c'est pas une mission à
l'écouler la perte est plutôt modeste
parce que c'est une nouvelle façon
d'explorer l'espace d'ici la fin de 2018
la nasa lancera également akon le
partenaire scientifique de gold qui va
orbite et liés à nos sphères à plus
basse altitude et fournir des images
plus précises de certains phénomènes
météo
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal